-We're back with
Jeremy Allen White, everybody.
Last time you were here,
we were talking backstage.
It was right after the first
season of "The Bear" had aired.
I think people who watched it
were huge fans,
but certainly way more people
have watched it now.
It must have been so exciting to
watch that wave of recognition.
-It was.
I mean, it was amazing to have
that many people kind of connect
with the first season.
But then I think -- yeah,
like, the first season,
we made in this bubble with,
like, no real expectations.
Nobody really knew
it was coming.
And then, yeah, preparing for
the second season was, uh --
was a little bit different.
-Of course.
Well, then you have
the burden of pressure.
People have these expectations.
I was so impressed
because I felt like it was --
and I loved the first season --
I felt like it was
an improvement.
And one of the reasons
it was an improvement
was there were huge risks.
It felt like there was
a tonal change,
and you guys could have
skated on what you had.
Were you all aware
as you started?
"Oh, look at this.
We're gonna actually
try to do something
a little bit more"?
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think you're right.
It was absolutely a gamble.
Kind of like doing
that tempo change, um,
and broadening the world
a little bit.
But, um -- But it worked.
And I think there's,
like, so much value in --
There were these great episodes.
Like, my favorite episode
of the season was "Forks,"
which was pretty much just Ebon,
who plays Richie on the show.
And I loved that one. Yes?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will say -- and I know
a lot has been said about it --
a lot has been written
about it, rightfully so --
the Christmas episode...
-Yeah.
-...I think, as we come --
there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think there should be
an annual tradition.
I think my family is
going to start doing it.
We're going to watch it
Christmas morning.
-Yeah.
-Just so we know
we're not that bad.
-Sure.
-You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-It's a real perspective-giver,
I think.
Watch it early in the day.
No matter how bad it gets,
it's like, "Remember,
at least we're not that bad."
-You can give yourselves
that gift.
-Yeah, I think that's
a good gift to give each other.
So, it's based on
this restaurant, Mr. Beef.
-Yeah.
-And the show creator,
he actually -- is that true
that he knew,
uh, the guy
who runs that restaurant?
-Yeah, Chris. It's two Chrises.
-Okay, great.
-The creator of the show
is Chris,
and the owner of the restaurant
is Chris.
Um, and, yeah,
they were in, like,
kindergarten together.
So, Chris Storer, our Chris,
who started the show, um,
he spent a lot of time
in that restaurant, growing up,
and, got to know it well.
And obviously, you know,
was a big inspiration
for making the show.
-Has the clientele changed
at Mr. Beef
since the show started?
-Yeah.
I mean, it's, like --
it's an old-school spot.
And I think, you know, I don't
think they've lost that crowd.
-Right.
-But, yeah,
now there's all sorts
of people that coming in.
that are fans of the show.
And I mean,
that's just, like, uh --
it's just such a nice thing
the show could do now.
You know, it's, like,
in the second season,
we visited
all these restaurants,
and now you have people
going to those restaurants.
-That's really cool.
-It's really nice.
-I bet that original group
of people that went to Mr. Beef
never even thought you could
Instagram a photo.
-No, exactly. Yes, right.
-They were like, "Do you know,
this whole time,
we coulda put this online?"
-Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-"All these likes,
we let go for nothin'."
Um, I've been working
on my Chicago accent.
-It's good. Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very excited
to have you here,
because this is clickbait.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It is clickbait.
-And I see it too often.
I don't know why the algorithm
is, like, you were like...
So, it's a thing that says,
"These grandchildren look
exactly like
their celebrity grandparents."
And here's the photo.
-You guys know.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, here's the thing.
That's you -- Uh,
that's you and Gene Wilder.
-Gene Wilder, who's amazing.
-Yeah.
And yet, even
if you click through --
Have you ever clicked on it?
-Well, no,
because I know
that that's not my grandfather.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I had no reason
to give that click.
-Give away a free click.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But it's so weird.
Even if you click through,
you don't ever come up.
-Yeah.
They're just baiting people.
-And I love --
because I will say
it's really good bait.
-Yeah.
-Because when you look at it,
you look at it
and your first thought is,
"Oh, how come I didn't
figure that out on my own?"
-You're kind of like,
"This is gonna be good."
-"I bet the other ones
are gonna be equally as good."
None of them are good.
-No. No, no, no.
-But have you -- have you
been hip to this?
Have people told it to you?
-For some -- Yeah.
So, like, during the first
season of the show,
I think people started talking
about the resemblance
that we bear, and it's --
I mean, it's true.
And I love him so much.
Like, the first film
I think I watched
over and over again,
as a kid, was
"Young Frankenstein."
And then I found
all the rest after.
But, yeah.
-That is -- It's really funny
that, I guess, there's,
like, a clickbait farm,
like, office, where a guy, like,
runs into his editor
and he's like,
"I think I got something!"
-And it's been months.
-It's been months!
Nobody nobody's gonna get tired
of finding out this isn't true.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Congratulations on everything.
The new film is great.
I'm so excited that everybody
has discovered "The Bear."
It is such a wonderful show.
And, you guys,
that's Jeremy Allen White.
-Thank you so much.
"The Iron Claw,"
theaters, December 22nd.
We'll be right back
with Hannah Waddingham.